hey 42 here I made the fifth 1821 one of
the most notorious men in human history
passed away that man was Napoleon
Bonaparte he had conquered most of
Europe driven armies into Russia taken
on the British Empire and changed the
face of history forever under now he was
dead but this isn't where his story
would end although his death was ruled
to be caused by a cancerous stomach
ulcer the real cause of his death has
remained in dispute to this very day
200 years later some consider he was the
victim of political murder as evidence
of long-term exposure to arsenic was
found in his hair of his pose that he
was killed by toxic fumes released by
his wallpaper whilst in exile on st.
Helena further theories indicates he may
have been the victim of medical
malpractice poisoning his body and
sending his internal organs into
disarray many more say he was killed by
disease and in descendants of
aristocrats say their ancestors killed
him in revenge for his revolution and
for the small fact that he fathered a
child with one of their wives
the count married to the wife in
question also happened to be in charge
of Napoleon's food could he have slipped
something poisonous into the Empress
foie gras to this day nobody knows
humans have a long and storied history
of wanting to poison each other hi Ron
my Apsara was a 17th century Roman
entrepreneur who taught wealthy wives
how to poison their husbands and take
their riches for themselves the Borgia
were famous for poisoning just about
everyone in existence karen wetterhahn
was a toxicologist and chemistry
professor in the late 90s who after
spilling a tiny speck of the methyl
mercury soon found herself slurring her
words slipping into a coma and
eventually
death despite the fact that the spilt
droplet had landed on a hand protected
by a rubber glove but what exactly is a
toxin and what is a poison are they the
same thing and how are they related to
that other nasty substance venom well
firstly poison toxin and venom and not
the same thing poisons are substances
that can cause harm or death to an
organism strychnine and lead are
examples of poisons toxins however have
mostly the same effects but they are
produced by living organisms or within
cells and venom aside from being a 7
foot 6 alien life-form bonded to a
disgruntled photographer is toxins that
are secreted and injected by animals
such as snakes that attacked their
victim cells nervous systems muscles and
more many animals have specifically
evolved to use these toxin rich Venom's
as means of attack or defense whereas
you have simply evolved to watch youtube
videos whilst you sit on the toilet
we've all heard about their notorious
poisons and toxins from Walter White's
ricin to the male platypus that attempts
to inject venom using its webbed feet
and the novel Chuck nerve agents that
damaged a central nervous system which
were used in the attempted assassination
of a former Russian agent in England by
a pair of Cathedral enthusiasts cerebra
our dalam the suicide tree releases a
cardio toxin that kills hundreds of
people in Southeast Asia and stir
neurotoxin botulinum is a gram for gram
deadliest substance in the known
universe
just edging out Justin Bieber's music
for the top spot which is ironic because
give him 10 more years and he'll be
injecting botulinum into his face
Botox that infamous Hollywood beauty
injection that transforms leather-faced
has-beens into balloon animals
is manufactured from the deadliest
substance on the planet but you don't
need to be an ex-spy to suffer from
deadly poisons what if I told you that
you come into contact with lethal
substances every day and you're
surrounded by one right now for a start
countless foods you eat such as almonds
barley soy beans and maize metabolize
into cyanide which if you don't already
know can cause you to vomit
yourself UNH's die just like a vindaloo
but don't worry your liver produces an
enzyme now denatures cyanide making it
harmless in sufficiently small
quantities but never ever eat the pit of
a cherry peach apricot or nectarine if
it is broken as the kernel inside the
pit once exposed to air produces cyanide
and swallowing just a couple of broken
cherry pits can kill a man and in case
you're thinking don't worry
I'll just wash them away with a juice
cleanse you should probably know that
whilst they may contain useful nutrients
and vitamins juice cleanses don't really
do anything to cleanse your bloodstream
of toxins your body can already do that
on its own very well it cleanses and
detoxing in general are one of the 21st
century's most prolific must consumer
scams but who or what are the primary
poison culprits in your daily life well
the most prolific perpetrator is none
other than the very thing that's most
essential to your survival
that's right the air is slowly
attempting to take your breath away
permanently and not in a Berlin Tom
Cruise eighties power ballad sort of
whereever air pollution has been a
problem for a long time in 61 80
Lucius Aeneas Seneca the younger took to
his Diaries who whined about Rome's suit
ridden air and how much better he felt
as soon as he'd left in 1274 a Londoner
became so Umbra verbal like coleus was
widely banned in 1948 Pennsylvania was
blocked out for five days in a cloud of
carbon monoxide sulfur dioxide and metal
dust burning the eyes and throats of the
city's residents in 2020 Australian
bushfires produced so much smoke that
New Zealand was temporarily turned
orange a country 2,000 miles away
separated by the Tasman Sea the air
you're breathing right now is probably
poisoning you especially if you live in
a city and if you happen to live in a
developing nation where solid fuel
consuming cook stoves are widely used
then you may find yourself victim to
indoor air pollution that claims over
3.8 million lives every year due to
inefficient use of solid fuel and
kerosene alongside this outdoor air
pollution from sources such as cars
manufacturing and even aerosol eyes
deodorant has become so bad that it has
been shown to take three years off your
life that's possibly worse than smoking
tobacco
a recent study at the University of
Washington concluded that air pollution
in cities is as bad for your health as
smoking 20 cigarettes a day whilst were
still uncertain which is the worst of
the two it is clear that most city
dwellers consume far more air pollution
than cigarette smoke the air in chat for
instance is so bad that it takes seven
point nine years of your life just
imagine it 7.9 years
could have spent watching my videos gone
forever air pollution can cause always
linked to health complications such as
pneumonia stroke heart disease pulmonary
disease lung cancer inflammation
arterial plaque buildup and more it has
even been shown in a 2014 study
conducted by the University of Rochester
Medical Center that early exposure to
air pollution damages the brain similar
to conditions like autism and
schizophrenia with lasting effects like
diminished short-term memory poor
learning and impulsive behavior children
are at particular risk because of how
immature their respiratory organs are in
the UK this causes an estimated 40,000
early deaths per year with London's
Oxford Street being one of the most
polluted roads on earth one in 12 deaths
in London is linked to it's dirty air
however if you want to sample the
world's most atrocious quality air you
need to head east almost all of the 100
most polluted cities are locations in
China and India but the West isn't far
behind
European air related thefts are
estimated to be as high as 800,000
annually not exactly the best scenario
we found ourselves in is it well it gets
worse not only is the air you're
breathing poisonous but the very
substance that you used to contain your
food water and waste is also filled with
poisonous chemicals I'm of course
referring to plastics if you thought
they were merely bad because dolphins
could get tangled in beer rings think
again and I'm not trying to take any
moral high ground here I use plastic
just as much as everyone else who
doesn't wear bamboo socks but the
science is a
scary writing for the Journal of
Epidemiology in Community Health a team
of scientists revealed that food storage
packaging processing and preparation
equipment contained over 4,000 chemical
substances one of which was formaldehyde
a highly toxic systemic poison and
category one B carcinogen in other words
a recipe for cancer alongside this
chemical such as bisphenol A BPA have
been widely used in plastics to make
them more durable and are regularly used
in transparent plastics the kind used in
storage containers and baby bottles
research has increasingly shown that BPA
use in plastics can disrupt many bodily
functions such as hormones and
reproductive systems there's even been
evidence that it's linked to abnormal
penis development in man and know I'm
sorry that doesn't mean abdominal arge
quite the opposite it's even suspected
to be linked to heart disease cancer and
diabetes the exposure to BPA is in the
global population is extraordinarily
high one study conducted by the CDC
demonstrated that in 2517 urine samples
from people 6 years and older BPA's were
present in a whopping 93 percent of them
likewise and one of the most commonly
used plasticizers in the world
phalates are equally widespread and
dangerous with links to pregnancy
complications and extensive fertility
issues one study showed but the level of
phalates in people's bodies who have 35
percent higher if they'd done some
finger simple as eating out the night
before the response to this startling
news has been a mixed bag BPA use in
baby bottles and feeding cups has been
banned in the US and EU but that's about
it
teenagers and adults are still widely
over exposed to plastics and their
related toxins
and often under educated and unaware of
the dangers they pose outside of david
attenborough's showing a turtle swimming
in an ocean of saints beach shopping
bags
BPA's continue to put male fertility at
risk by rapidly decreasing sperm quality
and repeated exposure over your lifetime
can alter your normal hormonal signaling
and cause you to develop countless
chronic diseases such as type 2 diabetes
breast cancer or artery diseases the
fret is ramified by the fact that
plastics once created extremely
difficult to get rid of if at all
possible in fact most of it remains in
existence scattered around the planet or
buried in Lund fills 79% of the 8 point
3 billion metric tons of plastics that
have been produced so far is buried in
the earth and constantly leaches toxins
into the soil which means that slow but
steady plastics poisoning is a big part
of all our lives and this probably isn't
going to change anytime soon but your
health will and for the worse this is
reinforced by the fact that when it
comes to recycling plastics nobody has
any idea on how to make them less toxic
in many ways recycled plastics are
actually even more toxic as nobody has
figured out how to remove toxic
additives from plastics recycled waste
products like desks tires or fences can
start to release dangerous toxins during
their degrading process with subsequent
recycling and usage only compounding
their toxicity it's little surprise then
that we're looking at health phenomena
like forty-year sperm count declines of
over 50 percent
we're being poisoned left right and
center by the air we breathe and the
plastics we touch yet there's one more
poisonous thing in your life that really
adds insult to injury oxygen that big
old bag of chemicals Ongina
keeps you alive
well that's a toxin - although we
breathe it in in your body uses it to
break down sugars and foods to produce
energy your body also produces oxygen
free radicals
what are those I hear you ask they're
atoms with one extra electron that
damages your dear name biomolecules
proteins and lipids which is the
biological equivalent of rust in other
words all that breathing we're doing is
keeping those alive sure but it's also
making goes age it's the one ironic
poison that we can never escape from
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video then please consider supporting me
you can either join the 42 club here on
youtube by clicking the join button
below or heading on over to patreon and
supporting me there thank you
you can also get your hands on a first
edition signed copy of my new book
sticker flagging it by heading on over
to ann bond publishing and pre-ordering
your copy today